und jetzt das heute journal
guten Abend die Debatte über die
europäische Asylpolitik wird hitzig
weitergeführt vor allem bei den Grünen
merkt man dass es da politisch ans
Eingemachte geht dass der Pragmatismus
den eine Regierungspartei zwangsläufig
haben muss bei diesem Thema für viele
überstrapaziert wird
hinterfragt wird allerdings auch und das
nicht nur von den Grünen ob die
behaupteten Wirkungen der EU-Reform
überhaupt so eintreten führt sie
tatsächlich zu mehr Solidarität unter
den EU-Ländern und zu weniger anderen an
den Außengrenzen
diese Diskussionen werden auch auf dem
Evangelischen Kirchentag geführt dort
war heute der Bundeskanzler zu Gast
Christoph Wiesel Bericht
Auftritt des Bundeskanzlers bei einem
Kirchentag der so politisch daherkommt
wie selten zuvor 45 Minuten lang stellt
sich Olaf Scholz in Nürnberg der
Diskussion rechtfertigt die
Regierungspolitik auch was die geplante
Verschärfung des europäischen
Asylsystems angeht wir müssen dieses mit
dem Finger auf andere zeigen und sich
unzuständig fühlen aufheben es geht um
Solidarität und aus meiner Sicht ist
diese Solidarität unter den Staaten die
gemeinsame Verantwortung ein faireres
Asylsystem als das heutige Protest rufe
immer wieder muss stolz in der
Messehalle dagegen anreden beim Thema
Ukraine kommen lautstarke Forderungen
nach Friedensverhandlungen aus dem
Publikum Scholz kündigt an bald erneut
mit russlands Präsident Putin sprechen
zu wollen doch für echte Verhandlungen
sieht er zurzeit kaum eine Chance was
nicht vernünftig ist die Ukraine zu
zwingen dass sie akzeptiert dass der
Raubzug den Putin dort gemacht hat
sanktioniert und akzeptiert wird und das
ein teil
und und das ein Teil des ukrainischen
Territoriums einfach Russland wird das
ist nämlich in Wahrheit der Plan von
Präsident Putin Krieg Klima Krisen dass
das in Nürnberg kontrovers diskutiert
wird sieht man bei der Kirche auch als
Lebenszeichen ich glaube was wir im
Kirchentag immer wieder haben und auch
zeigen
immer alle einer Meinung sind sondern
dass wir uns gegenseitig akzeptieren und
um Wahrheiten Ringen wie zur Bestätigung
kurz nach dem Auftritt von Scholz eine
Friedensdemonstration in der Nürnberger
Innenstadt morgen endet hier der 38
Kirchentag
die Linke hat heute in Berlin eine
kleine politische Bombe platzen lassen
zwischen der Parteiführung und ihrem
prominenten Mitglied Sahra Wagenknecht
ist der Umgangston ja schon lange eisig
als sie erklärte sie werde sich bis Ende
des Jahres Zeit lassen mit ihrer
Entscheidung ob sie eine eigene Partei
gründet war das Wohl der berühmte
Tropfen der das fast zum überlaufen
brachte die Linke sagt sich nun von ihr
öffentlich los und fordert sie und ihre
Mitstreiter auf ihre politischen Mandate
zurückzugeben
es ist deutlich geworden dass vor allem
Sarah Wagenknecht ihre Zukunft nicht
mehr in dieser Partei sieht sie hat den
Bruch mehrfach öffentlich vollzogen sie
hat mit der Linken gebrochen und das
heißt die Zukunft der Linken ist eine
Zukunft ohne Sarah Wagenknecht
Theo kann in Berlin hat diese ja
Erklärung denn jetzt irgendwelche
unmittelbaren Folgen
naja kurioser Weise könnten die Folgen
für die Partei viel dramatischer sein
als für Sarah Wagenknecht selbst der hat
die Linke zwar jetzt sehr laut die Türe
vor der Nase zugeknallt aber außer dem
lauten Knall heißt das erst einmal wenig
weder strengt die Partei einen
Ausschlussverfahren an noch kann sie
Wagenknecht zwingen ihr Bundestagsmandat
niederzulegen aber wenn Wagenknecht und
nur zwei ihrer Unterstützer wirklich
ihre Bundestagsmandate niederlegen
würden dann verlöre die Linke ihren
Fraktionsstatus und damit wichtige
politische Rechte und Möglichkeiten und
hätte sich im Grunde damit selbst massiv
geschwächtigt das war ja auch seit
langem wohl die Sorge der Partei dass
die Fraktion dann gespalten wird aber
geht man das Risiko jetzt halt einfach
ein
ja ich glaube die Partei Spitze hatte
salopp gesagt die Nase voll von
wagenknechts Dauerkritik und ihrem Spiel
mit einer parteigrundung man wollte
endlich wieder in die politische
Offensive kommen auch wenn das heißt
sich von der bekanntesten linken
loszusagen aber schon heute abend zeigt
sich der Tiefe Riss der sich jetzt
auftut gefährlicherweise auch zwischen
Partei und Teilen der Fraktion die
Fraktionsvorsitzende Mohammed Ali
spricht von einem großen Fehler heute
Abend ein anderer Abgeordneter von einem
weiteren Schritt Richtung Abgrund also
die Zukunft der Linken ist jetzt
möglicherweise eine Zukunft ohne Sarah
Wagenknecht aber ansonsten ziemlich
unklar danke schön nach Berlin
mit dem Blick in die Ukraine geht es
jetzt in den Nachrichten weiter Heinz
nachdem seit Tagen über den Beginn einer
ukrainischen Gegenoffensive spekuliert
wird Herr Präsident selensky jetzt gegen
Angriffe entlang der Front bestätigt
erklärte aber in welchem Stadium sie
sein werde er im Detail nicht sagen kann
er das Premierminister truido kam heute
nach Kiew zu einem Treffen mit Präsident
selensky thrido sagte weitere
Militärhilfen im Umfang von umgerechnet
und 350 Millionen Euro zu
angesichts des umfragehochs der AFD hat
Schleswig-Holsteins Ministerpräsident
Günther von der CDU auch seine eigene
Partei in die Verantwortung genommen
Günther sagte der Welt am Sonntag ist
gelinge als Union nicht ausreichend mit
überzeugenden Angeboten wahrgenommen zu
werden und die enttäuschten Stimmen
abzuholen
rund 13.000 Menschen haben in Erding bei
München gegen das geplante
heizungsgesetz der Bundesregierung
protestiert die Kundgebung hatte die
Kabarettistin monika Gruber mit
organisiert einer der Hauptredner war
Bayerns Ministerpräsident Söder er
kritisierte die Ampelkoalition
insbesondere die Grünen
im Waldbrandgebiet in Jüterbog südlich
von Berlin ist die Lage weiter
angespannt die Feuerwehr hat inzwischen
auch Luftunterstützung von Bundespolizei
und Bundeswehr die Löscharbeiten auf dem
ehemaligen Truppenübungsplatz werden
durch alte Munition erschwert
das Damenfinale der French Open hat egal
4tech aus Polen gewonnen mit zwei zu
Einsätzen gegen die Tschechien Carolina
muchowa die Zahlen vom Lotto dieses
samstags die lauten wie immer ohne
Gewähr 12 16 24 28 30 37 Superzahl 0 und
weitere Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zdf.de
Wetteraussichten der Sonntag bringt
Sonne und Quellwolken in den Alpen
einzelne Schauer 24 bis 32 an der Ostsee
22 Grad sonnig und sommerlich warm geht
es auch weiter erst am Mittwoch
entwickeln sich im nordostenschauer
und zum Schluss noch eine gute Nachricht
die schier unglaubliche Geschichte einer
Rettung über die die ganze Welt staunt
wie vier Kinder das jüngste noch ein
Baby erst einen Flugzeugabsturz über dem
Amazonas und dann mehr als fünf Wochen
im Dschungel überlebten völlig auf sich
allein gestellt bis sie heute von
Suchtrupps gefunden wurden die älteste
13 Jahre alt hat sich und ihre
Geschwister da heil durchgebracht ihre
überglückliche Großmutter kommentiert
das mit den Worten meine Enkelin ist
eine Kriegerin kann man Safia werden
ein Wunder so melden die Soldaten per
Funk nach 40 Tagen suche ziehen sie
Leslie solani tiernuriel und Kristin an
Bord ihres Hubschraubers
kurz zuvor haben sie die Kinder im
Regenwald gefunden erschöpft und
abgemagert aber lebend
ich sah ihre Gesichter und Augen voller
Hoffnung sie leuchteten die Kinder waren
voller Leben das Kleinflugzeug mit den
Geschwistern im Alter von 13 59 Jahren
das jüngste noch ein Baby war Anfang Mai
über dem Amazonas abgestürzt die Mutter
der Kinder und zwei weitere Menschen
sterben
wochenlang durch kämmen Soldaten mit
indigenen Helfern den Dschungel lange
Zeit finden Sie nur Windeln Fläschchen
und Fußabdrücke
sie waren auf sich allein gestellt sie
sind ein Beispiel für Überlebenswillen
das in die Geschichte eingehen wird
diese Kinder sind heute die Kinder des
Friedens und Kolumbiens
Kinder die Wochen lang im Dschungel
umherirrten umring von Schlangen
giftigen Pflanzen und Raubtieren
geholfen hat Ihnen dass Sie als
Angehörige einer indigenen Gemeinschaft
früh gelernt haben zu jagen und essbare
Pflanzen zusammen
alle wenn ihre Mutter arbeitete
aus dem Busch sie wusste was man essen
darf
die Angehörigen sind überglücklich die
Kinder die hydriert und voller
Insektenstiche werden mittlerweile
Militärkrankenhaus von Bogota behandelt
ein Happy End nach 40 Tagen im Dschungel
man denkt daran wie stolz die Mutter auf
sie wäre
was von uns und dann geht es jetzt auch
direkt mit der zweiten Halbzeit weiter
und um 0 Uhr gibt es die nächste heute
Express bis morgen tschüss
[Musik]